Okay, you know what?
I have to say it. I disagree with this comment.
Hear me out. Even if this is true,
that implies that 90% of men are inherently terrible at marriage
and only 10% are good.
Because 90% of women are ending marriages with your justification of,
we've told them a million times to change and they haven't,
and we checked out. Now,
this is true. All of my breakups in the past have been me checking out
six months prior to finally breaking out up with them.
I'm gonna get a lot of hate for this,
but here's the thing. Men want a very specific thing,
and it is to be valued and respected and loved,
just like we want to be loved.
I have seen men, including my own,
tell women, I don't want you to work.
I don't care if you make this much money.
I don't care if you think you have to be a boss, babe,
that is not what I want in home or in the bed.
But women will sit there for years and years and years
and try to change a man into being something that he is not,
as most men are not.
And then she will say that she is unsatisfied in the marriage,
and she will initiate the divorce.
I am speaking not only from statistics,
but also from cultural analysis,
all the research I've done and my personal experience.
Most of us want traditional men,
but We don't wanna be traditional women.
Most of us want high value man,
but we don't wanna be a high value woman.
Now, the value add is different in our eyes than it is theirs.
We think we're valuable because we make 80,000 a year and we're a boss,
babe, and we work a corporate ladder
and we have benefits
and he doesn't have to worry about bills cause I pay for half of them.
They don't want that. They don't care about that.
So what we think is valuable on the sex sexual marketplace,
in our eyes, it is not what men value.
And if you're gonna go buy a car,
you're gonna dictate what the value is.
The person of the car isn't gonna say what it is,
it's gonna be the person buying the car.
So if a man looks at a woman and says,
I don't really value this,
but they keep saying, no,
I'm a high valuable person,
I'm a high valuable wife, a woman,
you should marry me, it doesn't change what they inherently want.
And we think that this is so machismo or it's so toxic masculinity.
But holy hell,
how toxic is it to tell men what they think they should want
and tell them, no,
you're wrong, I'm valuable because I'm a boss, babe?
And they're like, hmm,
I would really be happy if you stayed home with the children and, uh,
you showed me respect when I came home and We loved each other,
and it was an equal relationship.
But we have been trained in our culture
that we don't wanna do any of those things,
even though biologically, it fits our gender roles. Right?
We were the ones who birthed the child,
were the ones that are meant to take care of them.
But I know so many women who will drop them off at daycare,
go to work, and the man will still say,
I would really much rather you be watching my children.
But they're like, oh,
my god, you're putting me in a box
because I wanna work, and I'm a boss, baby.
And you just don't respect me.
And your toxic masculinity.
Like,
I understand there are bad marriages,
but one, choose better from the beginning.
Two,
what we think is valuable is not what most men find valuable in women.
And three, we are constantly wanting them to change,
when in reality, a lot of women are not wanting to change.
And everything we've done for the last cent,
like, generation has been Guinea pigs in our culture.
Because I understand that we have equal rights and equal freedom,
but we've taken it a little too far,
and it is affecting relationships.
The biggest thing here is just listening to your partner.
We expect men to listen to us,
but do we listen to them? And I'm speaking from personal experience,
because there was a time where I insisted on being a boss.
Babe. And my husband told me over and over and over again
how he just didn't like it.
And the truth is, it didn't feed my soul as much as being here
with those two babies right now
and taking care of my home and him.
And guess what?
I have all the time in the world to be something different or bigger.
That doesn't mean it's just my title.
That's not my only label is mom and wife.
There's so much more to me.
And he sees that. He allows me to do things like this.
But, god,
we just. We expect so much from men.
And they were like, well,
we told him for years, and then we finally left.
And I just. I find it.
Find it unjustifiable to say that that is why 90% of women leave men.
So you're just implying that the entire nation,
all of our men, suck,
and that is why we do it. And it's okay.
That's my opinion.